welcome my friend and mentor and blur
her and all sorts of things a pass a cop
who in some ways the reason that I'm
here because his book the field guide to
the stars and planets which I first read
in 1984 it was in the second edition
background I still have a copy signed by
Jay was the inspiration that really got
me interested in astronomy
back in the 80s when I was a young
preteen and I maintained that ever since
so anybody who is know for some people
it makes it very happy that I got into
astronomy because of him others made you
know you may have referred a different
conclusion they blame Jay but throughout
that time throughout the last 30-plus
years Jay has remained an influence on
me both for a scientific acumen and for
his just all around I can't think of any
other work that's mention as' interest
in this matter
I'm Angela kite who is a renowned
scholar and her own writings sitting up
here in the front row who is also
honored me by being a reader of my book
but these are the books that have some
relation to the talk today one is a
standard astronomy textbook written with
Alex Filippenko a mutual friend of many
people in this room and it describes Jay
on the back or should have described him
as the field trip memorial professor at
Williams College where he's been since
nineteen two and of course perhaps the
world's foremost observer of
astronomical phenomena especially
eclipses transits syzygy z-- of all
flavors my favorite scrapple word and he
is here on an auspicious day because how
many do you know what today marks the
100th anniversary of that was right the
year that Primo levy was born very good
I'm very impressed by you guys knowledge
it's actually the centennial anniversary
today of the famous Eddington Eclipse
which tole solar eclipse which led to
confirmation on science theory of
general relativity so it's a very
auspicious day that he's visiting
depictions of the Eclipse on both
astronomical textbook for a course and
also this really interesting book called
cosmos and they both have very similar
pilot he's not very creative with his
titles the cosmos and cosmos with
subtitles tell much more and this is
written by a colleague at Williams right
Roberta Olsen oh but not Williams where
she Historical Society and my New York
Historical Society this is a work of art
and it's about astronomical art it's
just a phenomenal book I've only had a
few minutes to see it there's a
truckload of them er a boatload of them
coming all the way from overseas this
will be out hopefully over the summer
right this new newest book comes out
this is a compendium of art seen through
the lens of science or science seen
through the lens of art and it traces
it's astronomical phenomenon their
depiction throughout the centuries
through the lens of art just a
phenomenal book and a testament to just
a fraction of Jays fast intellect so
thank you Jay for coming to visit us
again thank you Brian I have had the
pleasure of observing a lot of syzygy
zazz Brian properly put it including
occupations of the Sun by the moon which
we call solar eclipses and I'm going to
talk mainly about solar eclipses today
and then at the end I'll go into some
other kinds of events that have stemmed
from the kinds of instruments that that
we use I'm spending my sabbatical this
semester at the Carnegie observatories
which is a pleasure to be at that
institution that we with which I've long
had an interest in association I will
talk especially about the eclipse of
2017 how many of you saw totality in
2017 so yeah yes so that's all it counts
and how many are going to see totality
in 2024 I expect the rest of the hands
to go up at that at that if you if your
hand wasn't up for for that at it it
should be but I'll talk about the four
total eclipses between now and then - at
some point but in any case as everyone
in this room knows
the it gets a million times darker so we
can't see a picture of the moon here
which has the solar corona around it and
and for the preliminary pictures we need
this these safe solar filters that let
only about one part the hundred thousand
or one part in a million of the light of
the light through little B oops I press
the wrong button and and then the
exciting phenomena that takes place at
an eclipse when we first see the
chromosphere which is actually what I
did my PhD work work on at the edge of
the Sun I'll say more about that later
and then the corona at different degrees
of distance from the Sun a little bit of
a solar prominence there which is a loop
of magnetic field that has turned to the
edge of the Sun and then as the moon
gradually covers the Sun and I'll say
more about that too we get this a bright
light coming through a valley in the
edge of the moon which we call the
diamond ring effect and then the shape
of the corona and you can see here
streamers that are going out controlled
by the magnetic field and also these
polar plumes that we now have visible
because we're at a minimum of the of the
sunspot cycle in which for a few years
we're not visible because there were
streamers coming out at all directions
the first person to actually map the
path of a solar eclipse and predict its
purpose on the it's passage on the earth
was Edmund Halley for the Eclipse of 17
of 1715 and we conclude the center of e
moon's shade we very near ye lizard
Point etc at the time and then he
actually asked people to observe it an
especially the duration of total
darkness with all the care they can for
the situation in dimensions this child
will be nicely determined so this is the
art in citizen science which we've been
pushing in in recent years and in fact
the the timing was offer some seconds
the distance was off some miles and he
read
the map with the actual position and a
prediction for the map of 1724 that
wound up going over the the continent
but here in California not far from here
in 1923 there was an eclipse and for the
Naval Observatory expedition to Oregon
for 1918 they invited an artist Henry
Howard Howard Russell Butler who had a
Princeton physics graduate who had
worked with Andrew Carnegie to to paint
the Eclipse because the film at that
time couldn't candle the dynamic range
and we didn't have the methods to
overcome those limitations of the way we
do the way we do today so he actually
got very interested in in painting the
eclipses he had a method of taking notes
in a few minutes he said I usually have
seven hours of for a sitting and now I
had to do it all in two minutes and of
course the oil was written subsequently
he got interested and did the California
Eclipse and later an eclipse from
Connecticut and lay still later and
eclipse from Maine and this triptych was
over the door of the entrance to the
Hayden Planetarium for the American
Museum of Natural History although now
it's in storage and and the butler did
work with carnegie up his picture that
includes Butler and and Carnegie it
convinced him to make a lake at
Princeton that some of you know and here
are the past of the eclipses that Butler
observed with with 1923 coming very
close to to where we are here and this
eclipse in 20 in 2017 went very close to
the 1980 path so for the first time in
99 years we had a coast-to-coast Eclipse
Eclipse like that some of you may
recognize the gentleman with a pipe so
Hubble did things other than then look
at galaxies so for those of you who
didn't raise your hand to come into the
10 to 20 for eclipse if Hubble could do
it you can do it too at the 1923 eclipse
and Butler went on to paint the
prominences which are
gasps held by the magnetic field off off
the edge of the Sun these are in storage
at the American Museum of Natural
History and I worked with Steve padilha
who runs the solar tower now at Mount
Wilson where they have all the back
plates going going back to in fact Hales
time in Kenwood Observatory before he
came to to California and we found a
number of plates to duplicate the the
prominences and other circumstances at
at the total eclipses that Butler that
Butler painted back to 1895 and the ones
we've we've talked about and and so we
have these wonderful prominence images
from a hundred years ago and you can see
here that that he really did accurately
follow the the prominences now one of
the things I've been interested in is
what we used to call the solar constant
the total amount of energy coming from
the Sun each second each square
centimeter but it was discovered as
probably everybody in this room knows
that it varies so it's hard to call it
solar constant if it varies so now we
call the total solar irradiance or TSI
and and NASA and and ISA have put up a
number of instruments that measured the
the total solar irradiance and you can
see how it anta correlates with the with
the sunspot number and and at the solar
minimum the Sun is a little fainter it's
a little brighter at so the maximum
except then you get some big sunspot
groups that eat that eden into that and
so this is a variation by a tenth of a
percent or so but you can see the
calibration differences were much more
significant than that and fortunately
over the last few years great cop of the
University of Colorado has recalibrated
everything we now have this this newer
scale and I'll come back to these
observations because we've used
observations like this and study
transits of Venus and transits of
Mercury
as Brian said today is an important
anniversary the hundredth anniversary of
the total solar eclipse of May 29th 1919
and Eddington arranged expeditions that
he went to sobral off the coast of
Africa
he went to principie now part of the
country of South Tomei and príncipe off
the coast of Africa near with now Gabon
and Crum Allen and Davidson went to
sobral in Brazil and the astronomer
royal Dyson stayed home in England
though he took the main role in in
reducing and reducing the data and this
interesting fellow whose picture you see
here though would younger at that time
had had the an interesting idea before
1914 that that the Sun the sun's mass
would distort space and the space would
bake the the starlight appear to deviate
and if you traced it back from Earth
you'd think it was slightly deflected
and the closer to the edge of the mass
the edge of the Sun the more the
deflection would be but it would be a
tiny amount and he wrote to George
Ellery Hale with this diagram but at
that time he didn't have the full value
calculated there but he did propose that
and and Erwin Finley foreign-looking
German astronomer went to the eclipse of
April of August 21st 1914 and my wife
and I had an article in space.com about
eclipses on August 21st which include
that one and also one viewed by Tico in
1560 as well as the one in 2017 and as
Finley frame like in his from Germany
crossed into into Russia on the way to
Crimea world war one began and he was
interned his companions were interned
the equipment was seized they didn't get
the equipment back for many years and
they did not observe the eclipses of
1914 which was fortunate for the history
and philosophy of science because
Einstein's prediction was not the full
prediction at that
and in the next couple of years he
doubled his prediction taking something
else into account and by 1917 he had a
fuller prediction of 1.75 arc seconds of
arc at the edge of the Sunna that you
can never observe quite to the edge of
the Sun and an Eddington
who was a pacifist Quaker stayed out of
the army and won and part of the deal
involved involved his working on the
Eclipse in 1919 to test relativity and
the Sun in 1919 was in Hyades so there
were lots of stars more than usual to to
make to make this test so it was unusual
for these Englishmen to test the idea of
a German scientist right after the war
and in the very interesting new book by
Dan Kenneth ik that no shadow of a doubt
you that just came out you can read a
lot of the background of of how the
observations were made and how the
observations were were reduced and
they're reduced under the eyes of Dyson
the astronomer royal Frank Dyson so the
accusations attending today are seen not
to be true though there have been much
discussed in recent years so here is one
of the plates from from nineteen this
particular plate is now owned by the
Niels Bohr library and it's you can't
really see these particular stars on
this on this plate but in any case in
November 1919 there was a joint issue of
a joint meeting of the Royal
Astronomical Society in the Royal
Society at which the results were
released and right away around the world
there were newspapers hailing this epoch
making a discovery British science a
British scientist calls the the
discovery one of the greatest of human
achievements now we can do a lot better
in testing the general theory of
relativity a number of ways including by
deflections which we now do with radio
astronomy and quasars and so for a long
time
there were no ground-based tests at
eclipses of the of the deflection of
light and people like me got annoyed
when everybody asked are you going to
test Einstein's theory because first of
all didn't need testing and second we do
different things that eclipses now we're
studying in particular the outer
atmosphere of the Sun which I'll get to
in a minute
but there now were at this most recent
Eclipse a few different tests so this
was released in 2019 but this is the
2017 eclipse and Richard Berry former
editor of astronomy magazine got these
observations with with these 42 stars
but the corona was too bright and
prevented the stars closer to the Sun
that would have given a bigger
deflections and the deflection we're
measuring is a sub-sub pixel but this
has been been worked on and they do have
a value that again endorses Einstein as
it must and Tobi Dietrich of Portland
state I believe had ten different sites
testing this eight of them failed for
one instrumental reason or another but
he also has some reasonable results and
Don bronze and optical physicist retired
optical physicist did a very careful set
of experiments with that also
he's right on the money even
unbelievably matching hein Stein's
result and Brad Schaeffer has has some
bigger shall we say bigger uncertainty
estimates then then Bruns came out with
so in any case this is going on the
Journal of quantum gravity published
bronzes ideas that why that journals and
whether those referees know what the how
to assess these things it's a
interesting question so anyway we had
this great anniversary today and there
are celebrations going on there's an
Eddington symposium in in Paris and on
the island of principie there is there
is a festival I just heard from the
current astronomer royal today Martin
Rees who blurb was kind enough to blurb
my text in he said he
they didn't go though he was invited to
fly down in a plane for black-tie dinner
on principie today but in Annie okay
okay so in any case if some of you know
about 365 days of astronomy a website
and blog I have today's piece on this on
this anniversary anyway let me go back
to to more modern eclipses and in
particular for the last half dozen or so
years we had this very nice Eclipse that
hit that went very near principie I was
tempted to go to principie and row out
in the boat for 40 miles or so but that
didn't wasn't good for the stability of
my cameras so we went on the ground to
Gabon and we couldn't go right in the
center line because we were warned that
elephants would come roaring through so
we went to the nearby town of makan go
do earlier there had been an eclipse in
Australia and we're able to compare what
this one here results from our
ground-based side in Australia with with
results from a ship to see motions and
then we do observe with radio telescopes
this was an annular eclipse but the most
of the radio radiation from the Sun
comes from the active regions from the
sunspot regions basically and we can get
higher resolution even from that at with
the VLA by the occulting and on
occulting by the leading edge of the
moon so we are carried so now we have
taken things of computer compositing of
dozens of images because the Sun is the
corona is a thousand times brighter here
than here so taking out that the
gradient allows us to see the structure
of the corona and here in 2013 we
actually see two coronal mass ejections
that were going out and we could trace
those back to imaging on in the extreme
ultraviolet on on the disk and there was
interrupting prominence here at the same
time and you can see from the streamers
or all around and the overall
symmetrical round axis of the Sun that
were at solar maximum and so we can
measure
what's called the flattening index and
that's been measured back into the 19th
century here's an 1896 point and and
when we're it's all a minimum the Sun
can be almost 30% elliptical and it's
called a maximum the Sun is pretty round
and we had a pretty round Eclipse in in
2013 and I'll get back to that and there
are some spacecraft up and and there are
a couple of different spacecraft that
observed the the center of the Sun in
the extreme ultraviolet so this is
pasted on what would otherwise be the
black image of this side of the moon and
then 25 years ago the European Space
Agency launched the Solar and
Heliospheric Observatory with a set of
coronagraphs run by the US Naval
Research Laboratory and and this is
rotated 90 degrees from the earlier
picture you saw but here's one of the
coronal mass ejections there and but
this whole doughnut of is between the
the EUV here and the the externally
occulted a coronagraph here and there's
even a further a coronagraph that it
caused even more is only visible in the
days of eclipses so only on the days of
total solar eclipses do we get a
complete view of the Sun and it's fun
when they put one of our composite
images as a stronger picture of the day
we did ultimately do some processing and
and you can get these better images of
the coronal structure with a higher
contrast and and then and then now the
NOAA results from the solar ultraviolet
imager go a little further out than the
everyday surface of the Sun but we're
still filling in this this doughnut and
we can certainly align the features that
we see at higher resolution that we see
it eclipses with the lower resolution
they have in the and the coronagraph
here and here's an example of one of our
higher resolution images of the coronal
mass ejections so when they're going out
to the side like that
they're not gonna hit us on earth but
every once in a while from the
spacecraft you see a halo event and then
it's coming towards you and in fact
there are things you can do if you have
some notice started turning off high
voltage and the thousands of satellites
going around the earth and try to save
them and and Naomi and I were recently
at the exhibit at the Science Museum in
London where they had Carrington's
actual notebook from 1859 when he saw a
white light flare and there's most
tremendous storm with Aurora's down to
low latitudes and the telegraph wires
sparking and if that should happen again
with all our satellites up in our
dependence and electricity things would
be a lot a lot worse so a lot of effort
is going into monitoring the Sun and
giving notice to when there are events
on the Sun we also take spectra of the
Sun I'll come back to this in a little
while remember what this looks like this
so here's an overexposed continuum here
but as the continuum goes away we get to
see these what are called slit 'less
spectra in the in this case because the
gradient of the solar chromosphere
itself acts as narrow band so it's
dispersed acts as a zone slit and in in
1868 the
Janssen discovered that there was a
yellow line that was not quite where the
sodium D lines were so we call the d3
and and then eventually Lockyer got a
spectrograph a few months later worked
with a chemist named Franklin and they
called it helium they said it was from
helium because it existed only on the
Sun and it took till 1895 till helium
was isolated in rocks from from Earth
and then the next year in 1869 a green
line was seen in the at an American
eclipsed by Harkness and young and they
called that corrodium said it must come
from caronian because it exists only in
the corona and this is the International
Year of the periodic table you can
learn all about that from my wife's
crossword puzzle in the latest issue of
physics today for celebrating the
International Year at the periodic table
or at our website at solar corona
dot-com you can link to her crossword
but in any case everybody here knows
that there is no element called
corrodium and it took from 1869 til the
early 1940s until it was realized that
this line is from 13 times ionized iron
and it has to be millions of degrees for
for the iron to be that ionized there's
an iron 10 line in the red here nine
times ionized iron and and we study over
the solar cycle the ratio of intensity
of iron 14 to iron 10 and the at at
solar maximum the corona is a little
hotter and we can actually see the Green
Line brighter than the red line and that
reverses that at solar minimum so we
have a series of that nice we made from
Gabon in in 2013
here is the sunspot cycle and and you
can see the peak here the different
hemispheres peaked at slightly different
times and we're now really coming into
solar minimum here and you can see the
spacecraft that have been up Soho all
this time and another Solar Dynamics
Observatory more recently and now the
solar panels on a goes spacecraft the
earth mapping spacecraft from NOAA are
looking out looking at the Sun while the
cameras the main cameras are looking
down to the earth
but now NOAA is mounting solar
telescopes in alongside the solar panels
so there's a new sequence of of solar
telescope Inigo 16 and goes 17 - to
monitor the the Sun let me go ahead to a
total solar eclipse that threaded the
Atlantic barely hitting the Faroe
Islands missing Greenland and Iceland
but going right over Svalbard which is
controlled by Norway half way to the
North Pole you can see how illumined how
elongated the shadow was at this point
around the curvature of the top
of the of the earth and we went to
Longyear beyond the capital of slough of
Svalbard and we got these excellent
observations you can see that it's not
quite symmetrical anymore we're going
past solar maximum working with a New
York musician Wendy Carlos is putting
together some of these images that look
more like what the eye puts puts
together and I'll come back to the use
of an image from the most reason two
clips are made with Wendy and joint
publication with zoar and Mick itch who
is here at predictive science Inc from
from San Diego and I'll come back to
this to the 2017 eclipse but here's our
joint image from the 2013 Eclipse here
with time-lapse well speed it up a
factor of 10 you can see the shadow go
by we were out on the ice because I'll
go back and do that again we had to get
past these mountains because the Sun had
to clear the mountains but if you went
further out than two kilometers from
Longyearbyen you had to have a rifle to
protect yourself from the polar bears so
we were located just under that that
level there and only one tourists we
know I've got mold by polar bears but he
was way out beyond where he was supposed
to be so we had these excellent
observations in 2015 from from foul
barred and oops let's see and and and
you can see here the coronal green line
very well for example or closer to solar
maximum there and here you see the
sodium line so here's D 1 and D 2 of the
sodium D lines and I meant to the yellow
lines and then here's D 3 which you see
is much brighter and that is the helium
the helium line the basic visible helium
lon
but the helium has to be excited to a
higher temperature than we get in the
photosphere to be obvious so so we see
that as well as a infra red line at
10:00 8:30 in from the from the
chromosphere here's the coronal green
line over over there and the red line is
fainter and because they just lit list
we get full full circles from the
coronal lines and only crescents went
facing one way or the other from the
chromosphere lines we I'm working with
an atmospheric physicist marcos pena
Loza mario from venezuela and we have
temperature measuring devices so it was
2 degrees fahrenheit in the morning and
when sun came up it went all the way up
to 8 degrees and then the moon started
covering the Sun and the temperature
went down to minus 7 and you see some
thermal lag after the center of of
totality before it resumed what it would
have done had it been a normal day at
that location of the sky was very clear
and we have published in the fil trance
of the Royal Society about the
observation of this a clip that had a
special issue especially of the effect
of but the partial phases throughout
throughout Europe and my article on the
total phases and we've published since
on other eclipses and the meteorological
effect of eclipses when there's an
abrupt shock to the Earth's atmosphere
of cutting off the sunlight the next two
eclipses that were total went across
Indonesia in 2016 and then of course the
American one and in 2016 we were at the
island of Trinity and it was pretty
cloudy but there were holes in the
clouds and we were fortunate to see all
the phenomena through the holes in the
clouds and ice prominence there for
example I am the chair of the working
group of eclipses of the International
Astronomical Union so we have people
from all over the world to help
coordinate the eclipses and help with
visas and shipping and various in
various things and we just added people
from Argentina and Chile because of the
locations the next two eclipses to help
us and then we have people who do actual
calculations and mapping and and website
with mapping and J Anderson does
cloudiness statistics and Glenn
Schneider calculates aircraft
trajectories and Michael Gill runs solar
eclipse mailing lists in which we all
keep in touch and these other people are
mappers or or my country NOx was in
charge of the double-a s task force and
Ralph
how does important things about ice ft
so in 2017 the Eclipse went a
coast-to-coast across the United States
for the first time since 1918 as you saw
so we were in Salem there and of course
the partial phase has covered the whole
country and the weather statistics were
better in the West so most of us went to
the West had just tipped Kansas City and
st. Louis at the at the edge was a
little cloudier in that in that period
and went out to sea near Charleston
South Carolina and then ended at the
Atlantic in in Sunset and tens of
millions of Americans saw that saw that
Eclipse and when we have these wonderful
images Allen's Liske is coming with me
next next month so we'll see what
permanence is there are but here's
beautiful features in a prominence at
the edge of the Sun during the the
Eclipse and composite image at high
contrast made with some colleagues where
to roost in Roman roamin veneer and in
our recent nature astronomy articles are
and used druk Millar's similar high
contrast imaging but we also have our
own capabilities of doing this this high
contrast imaging and we'll discuss what
we what who which images were used for a
similar paper from the from the
forthcoming Eclipse but we're certainly
very pleased with with the quality the
sky was was gorgeous and clear beautiful
polar plumes you can really see the
three-dimensional porcupine structure
projected back on the plane of the of
the sky so we're really very pleased
with what we have from the 2017 eclipse
we were there in in Salem as as the
Eclipse path went over but turns out if
you actually calculate the shadow the
shadow is not actually elliptical
because the the
it turns out that the irregularities at
the edge of the Moon have to do with the
projection of the shadow on the earth
and then it interacts with the
mountainscape on the surface on the
surface of the earth so we have so we
actually have results about the the
details of the predictions having do
with the shape of the moon that's now
been measured from the lunar
reconnaissance Observatory from NASA and
the Kaguya spacecraft from from Japan I
do travel not only with scientific
colleagues from all over but also with
students from Williams College we had
eight students from from Williams and
and four of our alumni who are
astronomers or graduate or graduate
students and that occasion we were set
up at Willamette University with a whole
lot of apparatus at and at that at that
time and it's very good for us all and
through the IAU we also had had some 50
Japanese cisterna MERS and 28 chinese
astronomers who joined us on me on the
site the day was completely clear and
and we just had a beautiful diamond ring
and nice prominences and and then here's
the inner corona I did have a Scientific
American article to orient people across
the country and and let me just use a
little bit of the orientation that of
course here we all know the surface of
the star is closer to 6000 kelvins but
then there's some energy input and the
and the chromosphere
is perhaps 10 times hotter than that on
the on the whole the prominences are
chromosphere 11 gas at 60,000 degrees or
so but then energy is injected into the
into the corona and you have to not only
inject it but also make it stay there to
heat the corona to millions of degrees
of course it's it's a low very low
density so it doesn't take much energy
to make the particles go go very fast
and I have been saying for a long time
that there have been that the problem of
just how the corona is heated to minor
degrees has been solved that it's been
solved by 12 different
people in 12 different ways and then at
a meeting of the triple-a assets which
Steve Cranmer from Boulder spoke last
year he actually listed 19 different
solutions so it's a major unsolved
problem in astrophysics which of the
models of the heating of the corona is
correct and some of what we're doing is
testing is trying to make observations
that that distinguish between the
results of different theories and
particularly making power spectra of
high frequency observations in this in
their limited coronal lines which is not
what everybody sees most people don't
have these these coronal Corona filters
so we take advantage of the days of
eclipses to carry out these these
observations and here is one of our
starting Picture of the Day images from
a month after the Eclipse and you can
see how they there were very few
streamers that at that time coming at
the solar minimum you could see the
polar plumes you can see our fill-in of
the donut that is within the occulting
disk here on the ultraviolet image then
from the Solar Dynamics Observatory you
could see that there was a coronal hole
here a low-density looked at the
relatively low temperature region of the
corona in this extreme ultraviolet image
but it is a real effect if you're
looking down with a weather satellite
you can actually see the shadow of the
moon across across the earth if you were
on the moon as and this is a robotic
observer the Lunar Reconnaissance
Laboratory orbiter could see I could see
the shadow and if you were an astronaut
you could just take your camera up to
the glass and and see the silicon I
would love to see that someday see the
shadow of the Umbra here and I worked
with Ernie Wright of the Lunar
Reconnaissance Orbiter program and we
took our timed observations of the of
the
Bailey's beads here at the at the edge
of the Sun in ingress and egress and
because now we have detailed
three-dimensional mapping of the shape
of the corona of the shape of the edge
of the moon and you can get the
librarian right and make the predictions
right and so the variable is really then
just the size of the Sun and we have a
small deviation that we recommend to the
IAU for the size of the Sun they use in
the model for for predictions in any
case to get back to the heating of the
corona here for my Scientific American
article here's a drawing of a coronal
loop and it could just be that there are
nanoflares going off all the all the
time on the Sun very small flare like
objects or we could have alpha in waves
bouncing back and forth which normally
would take seconds or tens of seconds or
there could be surface alpha in waves
which give sub-second periods and so we
are working on on making measurements in
the coronal lines and taking out the the
variations from the atmosphere I've been
working in particular with Mike person
of MIT we have here in door frame
transfer cameras that we use for our
occultation studies and here we have a
red line and green line a filter and and
we made these observations at three at
three Hertz in in Salem and we're still
studying those data we do have some
spectra some from earlier observations
earlier eclipses that that do tend to
favor some extra power at short short
frequencies but we still are working on
these on these data here so here's a
sample red line and green line image you
can see a little structure and of course
that will come out more as we study it
in in detail and we were observing this
region on the edge of the Sun with a
ghost 16 image in the background here
here's a combination my student
Christian Lockwood made combined with
the
extreme ultraviolet from from goes Suvi
and we can really see the polar plumes
and and the streamers and this guy was
so clear we can really see the streamers
much further out than the last Gale
coronagraph and we have much higher
resolution so we do what we can in the
overlap in the overlap regions and then
a colleague observed observed from
Carbondale Illinois which was 65 minutes
later in the passage and you can
actually see some features here for
example moving quite a distance in only
one hour and you can see changes in in
some of the plumes here and variations
in in the streamers and the fine
structure of the streamers so we are
busy studying the dynamics of the corona
and measuring the velocities that that
occur there in the in the Sun so here we
are in the current part of the sunspot
cycle the yellow are the daily
observations you can see that most days
there's nothing on the Sun at all so I
can't even predict whether there'll be
any sunspots on July 2nd for the
forthcoming Eclipse and then we expect
there to be some some rise but it's been
controversial just what the next spot
will be are there some longer periods in
addition to the 11-year your period
what's going to happen next and and
David Hathaway just that a panel of
experts just made some some predictions
and it might be another low cycle in the
next time but there's some possibility
there'll be no cycle at all or the next
on visible spots and different people
have different predictions but this is
the latest committee result another
another low cycle coming up we do have
the spectra from together made with my
colleague eros vulgaris from from Greece
here the iron 14 Green Line faintly
visible there his that here's the red
line a little stronger at this phase and
the sunspot cycle and here's the helium
line for example with a little bit of
sodium there H H beta H alpha there and
and then we have these these images in
the
a red line and the coronal green line
and and we can see the the different
structure and the temperature structure
as it varies with position in the in the
corona here's a little more magnified
here's the coronal red line so these are
all from the 2017 eclipse made there and
here's and here's the green line higher
dispersion spectrograph so we will have
those spectrographs on the top of cerro
to Lolo as I was awarded one of the five
observing spots at in Sarah to Lolo for
the Eclipse that's coming and of course
we've scanned the lines the lines there
and the red and green line and seen the
orientation to where it is in the Solar
in the solar corona and then much
fainter than than the red line and the
Green Line is an argon 10 line and I
borrowed a Leo filter a high-quality
calcite series of filter of high purity
from the Big Bear solar observatory and
Eris vulgaris has modified it to the
argon 10a wavelength which is a weaker
Lauren but we expect to get the first
high quality imaging of argon ten at the
Eclipse that's coming in about five five
weeks so so here it is in a slit this
spectrum but we hope to have more detail
than that next next month and you can
see here the actual spectral line is
just is just weaker but we do have this
capability now and we are working today
even and shipping it from Greece to to
Chile Brian is an expert in getting
equipment into into Chile and so we're
working on that anyway using one of
these goes 16 images with our image and
to make a compound here you can see this
solar minimum situation in 2017 and we
expect it to look somewhat similar in in
2019 just to remind you what happens at
solar maximum this is an old image from
20 years ago it's solar maximum when
there are dreamers all around
at including high latitudes so but now
we're at solar minimum and so in fact
here is the the 2016 point about halfway
down and then the 2017 flattening index
is up around a quarter with Marcos
pendulums Mario and Michael Roman and my
senior who just graduated Ross you from
Williams College we have observations of
the winds and and here's the radiation
all all going away here and well here we
see the wind died down and the and
during during totality and and we can
see the atmospheric pressure at the
onset of the of the Eclipse and here's a
change in the wind speed and the solar
radiation of course went to zero over
there and you can see the dip in the
temperature so we'll be making
measurements like that again this year
and Ross worked with weather stations
across the country inside and outside of
totality for his senior thesis so in any
case we're very happy with what we had
from 2017 I was very pleased to work
with Zoran who's here and his colleagues
Connor down John linka and they use
satellite measurements of the magnetic
field for the preceding month or so to
make a prediction of what the corona
looks like will look like and this was
released before the before the Eclipse
but a week before the Eclipse and you
can see the streamers that they
predicted and the plumes that they
predicted and I'm pleased that one of
our smooth images maybe Wendy Carlos was
used to compare with with their
prediction and you can see the results
are actually quite quite in agreement
here in fact is the diagram from the
nature astronomy article with an a
higher resolution so here's our image
from from Salem and here's a composite
image with a higher contrast made by a
missile
Miller with observations from Peter
annual and Sharia hobble and here there
there are predictions here the predicted
magnetic feed lines particular eyes
brightness so we look forward to doing
that again next month and so it's less
than four weeks from today that will get
their prediction and about five weeks
till we get the observations you mean
Wang of NRL also makes some magnetic
field calculations and we can see
whether it was a helmet streamer and and
I don't have time to go and he tale but
the active region at the e-string
a east limb and and so here's our
composite and we can link and we can
link that all link that all up here with
those predictions and then you can look
to see what the Sun would look be like
in 3d if you look from the east or you
look oh you look from the West and NASA
has us a pair of spacecraft stereo of
which one is still operating that is
part way around the Earth's orbit so we
get actually a three-dimensional view
history of you I just got the spectra
from Richard Berry the former editor of
astronomy magazine just to show you they
the what's littler spectra are like and
just at the origin a beginning of what
we call second contact there'll be some
overexposed continuum that will go away
and you can you can see those those
chromis fearing lines in the slit in
this little spectrum and in totality and
then he comes out the other side you can
see the individual spectra of the of the
prominences and then and then the bits
of chromis fear and bits of photosphere
emerge from the from the Baily's beads
and so here all the labels but you can
see the the well the prominence images
there and you can see here the helium
some helium there and some sodium there
and and so there are a lot of
chromosphere clients we have used the
expanded Owens Valley solar array with
del Gary especially
of New Jersey Institute of Technology
and the blue is the model of the advance
of the moon and you can see when the
active region is covered over and
uncovered and so we get very accurate
position so we and we can correlate
those with the x-ray observations from
the Sun and my alumnus mu Joe Liu drew
through these VLA from when we were at
the VLA with something similar in 2012
and we did use the VLA again this this
time and here's a Solar Dynamics
Observatory background but we did have
an active region that we could that we
could study and here's how far we get in
one minute so by taking observations
every second or so you can see the high
resolution that we that we get so these
are VLA radio contours at 2.8 gigahertz
for example so so we've been working
with these VLA data to pinpoint they
where the radio emission comes from and
there is a radio telescope that's from
an ESA tracking station in Argentina
that we'll be using for the next two
eclipses and we have arrangements with
ESA and the people there to make those
observations I did help propose this
mega movie where we had citizen science
all across the country led by Hugh
Hudson especially of Berkeley and and
finally there was this big mega movie
project and there are thousands of
contributed over a thousand contributors
and we have as a big archive online to
to work with and that will be even more
elaborate in 2024 and then I mentioned
the stereo a and and here's the position
of the earth but stereo advanced is
ahead of the Earth's orbit from this
different point of view and and B has
failed now but but but we do have these
observations that we can match up with
the theoretical predictions from from
the sides and I mentioned the solar
ultraviolet imager this is not during
the Eclipse but you can see the quality
of the observations the coronal hole
there the eruptions that we
that we see so we will have the data
again from ghost 16 and 17 for this
Eclipse and the ghost sequence is funded
by NOAA and should be working for at
least 20 20 years I do have a website as
I finish the part of my talk about the
Eclipse at total solar eclipse org with
70 different eclipses that I solar
eclipses that I have observed and for
the IAU will run a website at eclipses
dot info so that's just an easy URL to
remember and we have links to various
mapping and then I had a resource letter
in the American Journal of physics with
all kinds of references to eclipse
related things including the relativity
and there was one to the International
Year of astronomy and in 2009 and then
we updated that for the American Journal
of physics and in nature astronomy for
all kinds of of articles now I had a
little withdrawal in 2018 because there
was no total or annular eclipse anywhere
in the world in 2018
so there were three partial eclipses so
Naomi and I went to Buenos Aires for a
16% eclipse in in in February which was
which was very nice and of course I get
to practice with some equipment and
check on things and and do some public
outreach here we are on the roof of a
hotel in winners IRAs and then in on
July 13th the eclipse was over
Antarctica and extended to just barely
to Melbourne and we went to Tasmania
where we were at the grounds of the
Mount Pleasant radio Observatory and and
got beautiful observations and and I
learned a lot about pulsars from a veil
a glitch that they had observed and then
in August 11th we went to Stockholm and
here's ground-based observation from
from Stockholm the weather was bad
further north where there was the deeper
eclipse and here's the spacecraft a view
of that eclipse and then early in 2019
there was an eclipse that bit we did
reach Alaska but they're very low in the
sky so I went to Tokyo for for that
Eclipse which was really very
interesting to do and I got to work with
my colleague dr. Honoka who will be near
near me on Cera to Lolo for the
forthcoming Eclipse and dr. he a is a
noted Japanese solar astronomer and
others are observers there in a
colleague and then sometimes there were
just eclipses that don't reach us on
earth ago 16 had an extra partial
eclipse and you have to know about these
things because the yoko spacecraft from
japan actually was surprised by one and
it spun out of control and died and
that's one of the few negative things I
know about eclipses but you have to make
sure that there's no eclipse is going to
sneak up on your on your spacecraft here
and that particular Eclipse knew was
really a quite a substantial thing
anyway in a month or so in July 2nd 2019
as an ecliptic was over the Pacific near
sunset it reaches the Pacific coast of
Chile and we intend to observe from the
centerline right right here at this at
this location and then it ends at sunset
over in Argentina but we want to get as
high as possible
from from land there and only crosses
one island a little island in the middle
of Pacific oh we know Island Sarah to
Lolo is in the path of totality a little
off-center but but still yes more than 2
minutes of of totality and I have as I
as I mentioned observing lots of four of
our team they're Las Campanas is just
off the edge so those poor people have
to descend from the mountain and travel
into totality to to see it so in 2019
the eclipse ends here after the Pacific
in 2020 in the summer time the Eclipse
central point is actually in Argentina
and so on that occasion we've arranged
to be on the coast here and then O'Brien
is working
also have some people in in Chile so
they can visit his Simon's Observatory
afterward but but here we go through
through lower lower Chile and the peak
here and we'll be in las grutas right on
the coast on the center line in December
14th 2020 in the summertime there and
then in 2023 there'll be an annular
eclipse from Texas to Oregon and so
you'll get a pretty deep partial eclipse
here in in San Diego actually a better
partial eclipse than then for the total
eclipse that will go from Mexico to
Texas to Cleveland to New England in
2024 and so this annular eclipse in 2023
goes over the western part of the United
States and 2024 the weather is usually
better in April in Texas than it is in
New England so I'm anticipating being
there but we're looking at the how to do
statistics so we just had this very
exciting time at the at the Eclipse in
in 2017 we don't have sound that the
people are starting to cheer at this
point you can see the shadow over
overtake the the earth you can actually
see far enough away that it's a little
bright and arising because we're seeing
100 miles away and we have totality
there and it just worked very very well
anybody want to guess what this is Mars
so this is an eclipse of the Sun by
Phobos from Mars recently sent down from
the Curiosity spacecraft and there's
actually a song that goes with it from
Sean Lennon the monolith of Phobos I
just learned about which I won't lie
here and but you can actually see the
sky darkened from the from the Eclipse
from from curiosity and then Deimos
so there are these eclipses of the Sun
which are almost like like transits if
you happen to be on Mars and of course
the resolution is it's good that's still
pretty good for Mars I want to take just
a few minutes now that we're almost
finished for some observations we've
made of other things that go in front of
the Sun beside the moon oops so mercury
is just a little thing smaller than a
sunspot and but from the Big Bear solar
observatory in California where I had
the good fortune to be a postdoc many
years ago we can get these really
high-ups of her resolution observation
this is really very impressive of
mercury going in front of the solar of
the solar granulation and so this is
what we did in 2016 at the transit of
mercury and we look forward to doing
this again on November 11th this year
and as a student exercise I worked with
some people in Germany as well as Glenn
Schneider Arkham a physics teacher in in
measuring the parallax of measurements
from from Germany and from and from
California and the sharper images are
ours for Big Bear of course but but we
can measure that that parallax effect
and that's a good student observation
and we also measure the the sodium tail
of mercury but we have observations also
from Sacramento peak that we're also
arranging for this coming November the
total solar irradiance does drop by 1%
and that we could measure this was the
active cavity radiometer and radiance
measurement the device that was aloft on
its own on its own spacecraft that's no
longer working
but for Mercury it's a much smaller it's
a much smaller effect and this was from
a spacecraft from Greg cop of the so
called total irradiance measurement on
the source NASA's source spacecraft and
so here is the 2012 Venus transits of
the
transits are easy in total solar
irradiance but Venus itself is big
enough on the surface of the Sun that
you can even see it with barely with
your eye if you're just looking through
a solar solar filter whereas mercury
isn't much smaller so we have been
following this along here's the 2004
transit of Venus and the 2012 transit of
Venus and and then we did but we weren't
satisfied with just these two transits
of Venus if you happen to be on Jupiter
there was then a transit of Venus a
couple of months later and we managed to
get a full day of 14 orbits of the of
the hubble space telescope to study
Jupiter to see if we could see it
dropped by a hundredth of a percent in
intensity from the transit of Venus and
these are related to EXO planet transits
and the limit of what you can what you
can measure so we do have these great in
two color observations hundreds of
individual frames but but the brightness
of Jupiter because of its clouds varied
by three percent that we were actually
unable to pick up the hundredth of a
percent variation on the variation of
the of the three percent background but
but since we had 14 orbits and 170
exposures of Hubble we could see the
Great Red Spot we were able to use that
together with Theodora Kyra Liddy Daniel
a PI and and some others to test them
some code for mapping a brown dwarf
atmospheres and finding spots on
exoplanets and so we were able to get
some useful app up J article out of that
here's here's our our discussion there I
won't dwell on this and then and then we
we couldn't see it just nothing was
going on from the from the earth but
from in a few months later there was a
transit of Venus as seen from from
Cassini and and we and we tried to work
with the Cassini people and we got a
marginal detection in the most sensitive
infrared channel and this again is a
limit
what the exoplanet people can can hope
to see because we're seeing the detail
of what goes on and then and then just
quickly the 2003 mercury transit and the
2006 mercury transit because there are
over a dozen mercury transits per
century and this was the one in 2016 and
now we're looking to 2019 November 11th
the trends will be in progress and
sunrise here in California it will be
fully visible in the eastern United
States and the Canary Islands and and
we'll try to make some comparisons there
and then really just to finish in a
couple of minutes I've used our
high-speed imaging that you saw with the
red and green lines without a filter
starting with my colleague Jim Elliott
at MIT to study occultation zuv stars by
Pluto and other objects and just before
New Horizons went by we we did get a
light curve from the mount john
observatory including the central flash
from focusing because we were just in
the right spot to to image the stars it
went behind the behind the whether you
are coating object Pluto and there were
observations from Las Campanas also here
and as you know when Pluto went when New
Horizons went by it turns out to Pluto
days which is twelve Earth days later we
got these wonderful images of Pluto and
Charon here they are really with the
distance to scale and then Mark Bowie
found three objects of picking them out
of a star field that the spacecraft was
going more or less straight at because
we've got a nice spacecraft out there
with a lot of instruments and if you can
find something that he can get to with
the amount of fuel it has that's worth
doing so on January 1st this year the
spacecraft went to one of those objects
2014 mu 69 from the 2014 you can tell
that it was only discovered in 2014 and
they therefore didn't know precisely
enough where it was to
only 2,000 miles from it so there were
three occultation z' of the object and i
participated in the team with our
instrumentation with well our methods in
their instrumentation of June 3rd 2017
and then Sofia flew in the middle of
July and there was another orientation
further south you see so we're almost
matching the Eclipse paths here in in
2017 and and the first time we had flat
light curves and and didn't pick up the
object which was just off the off the
edge but the we had the gaya catalogue
and a lot of careful work was done and
finally in 2017 I didn't go because it
was closer to the Eclipse 23 stations
worked with 16-inch telescopes that NASA
had bought and they got 5 occultation
cords so here's where my team here for
2014 mu is 69 and under the southern
others under the beautiful southern sky
where we we did get clear sky these
observations that that didn't show a dip
but in 20 July 17th every 10 kilometers
or so there was a picket fence to to
pick up the the images and there were
these five occultation zuv half second
to second and a half and and it showed
it wasn't round and gave this this
strange shape which could have been
duplicated by a binary object and and
the idea was that there really might be
a binary object that they have a whether
was contact or whether it was orbiting
was or was not known but when the
observations were actually finally made
you can see that it really is a binary
object stuck together you've all seen
some of these pictures it's only 21
miles across it's known as Ultima Thule
from an old name from a couple of
thousand years ago for something beyond
the far north and there's a little
brighter in the neck and the obito's
between around 6 and 12 percent or so
and and the data are still coming back
there's a camera with a lower resolution
that gives color information to give the
the composites of air and then as the
spacecraft came by at 32,000 miles an
hour
it really gave great observations and
but also explained where the light curve
didn't very because it was more or less
a pinwheel with the axis pointing
pointing at us and and so they're just
the finest resolution as it came close
and they really did a wonderful job in
pinpointing yet because we had these
occultation observations and I'm very
pleased and proud to have participated
in in those studies and then they had
this idea that it was well called even a
snowman of these two primitive objects
from 4.6 billion years ago that have
been unaltered for all this time 33
kilometers or so across here and here's
the highest resolution observations when
and when it came back but then it turns
out they sent back the data from when
the spacecraft passed by and looked back
and the coltd stars and from that they
could reconstruct the three-dimensional
view and the three-dimensional view
turned out not to be too primitive round
objects
but rather 1:1 flattened one indented
like that which was a surprise and so
now just a couple weeks ago there was a
science article with these first results
and it's really just fabulous is really
just fabulous stuff and it's a lot of
fun and it uses the kind of
instrumentation that we've been using to
study models for the coronal heating and
so that's what I have to say the
eclipses and a few other things and I
thank you very much and I think Ryan for
inviting me
[Applause]
you